يضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري واستراتيجي اللواء الدويري
بعد 10 اشهر من الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا كيف ترى ما تحقق حتى الان بنسبه
للطرفين
هو انجاز بالنسبه للجانب الاوكراني لانه
القراءات الاولى والتسريبات الاولى
والتصريحات حتى والتقديرات من السي اي اي
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان الحرب سيكون
عمدها فقط 96 ساعه ثم ظهرت تقارير لاحقا
خلال الاسبوع الماضي كذلك همم ايضا من
الشيعه ايه بناءا على معلومات من محيط
الرئيس بوتين ان القراءه الاولى كانت
تتوقع ان يتم حسب الامر خلال عشره ايام
فها هو الان بدل كل يوم شهر ولم تنتهي
الحرب اثنين كانت القراءات ان الجيش
الاوكراني الذي يستطيع الصمود وبالتالي
التوجيه السياسي كان يتحدث عن
السيطره على اوكرانيا همم نزع النازيه
التخلص من المنظومه السياسيه الى غير ذلك
اذا دعني اقول ان مجرد صمود همم اوكرانيا
سواء القياده السياسيه او العسكريه لهذا
العمل من من الزمن اا ضد ثاني جيش في
العالم يعتبر شيء ايجابي وحتى ان مستوى
الخطاب السياسي ال- في البدايه كان مستعد
للعوده الى اتفاقيه ماسك ولكن الان
المطالبه كما شرط انه يطالب بالقرم ليس
فقط للمناطق الاربعه بالنسبه للجانب
الروسي
قياسا مع قدراته العسكريه الكامله في
ابعادها البشريه والمعدات وغير ذلك لا
تعرضت الى انتكاسات وحتى اكثر المحللين
تشاما لم يكن يتوقع سوء اداره المعركه
الروسيه بهذا الشكل لماذا لانه استنادا
الى التسريبات طيب
ومقارنتها بالمجريات نجد انهم فشلوا في في
كيف في خارف في خيرسون وبالتالي
لا اقول استنفذت كامل طاقات ولكنها
استخدمت اقصى طاقه ممكن ولم تحقق النتائج
المرجوه فهمنا منك بان الاهداف الروسيه
تبدلت هل لهذا انعكاسات على المسار
السياسي في وقت الان تتوافر فيها
التصريحات الغربيه المطالبه بواضع حد
للحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
يعني الان اذا اذا اخضعنا خطاب الرئيس
جنسكي
واعتمدناك اساس هذا الوقت ليس وقت مفاوضات
لماذا لانه هناك اقليم دومباس اجزاء كبيره
من زاباجيا من خيرسون بقايا من مايكو لايف
همم تحت الاحتلال الروسي وبالتالي الذي
يحسم الاتفاقي اي حرب تنتهي بالتوافق
بالتفاوض ولكن المفاوضات
مرتكزها الاساسي الواقع الميداني الواقع
الميداني موجوده النظر الاوكرانيه هناك
اربعه مناطق محتله وعلى القرم تعتبر رقم
خمسه اذا هذا الوقت امتثالا لتوجهات
القياده الاوكراني هو ليس وقت التفاوض
لانها لم تحقق ما يجب
لو سمحت بدقيقه اذا كيف تسال هذا الضغط
الغربي
بمعزل ما يحصل على الارض بدقيقه واحده
السبب المعاناه في قبل فصل الشتاء وخوف
الانظمه السياسيه الغربيه بان مشكله الغاز
والنفط
مضاجع هذه الشعوب وهذه الشعوب تقول ان هذه
ديمقراطيه ويمكن ان تسقط هذه الحكومات
وبالتالي هي تزرع الخطر عن نفسها ولو على
حساب الطموح الاخراني شكرا لك اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري واستراتيجي في
عمان